Stradivarius violins are considered some
of the finest musical instruments ever
made for centuries they've been played
on the world's most famous stages from
Venice to Hongkong Cremona is the
Italian city that gave birth to those
violins now people who live there are
being told to be as quiet as possible
because of an ambitious project to
preserve the sounds of these
million-dollar instruments Seth Doane
went to Cremona to see the project
firsthand this road is closed the
parking lot cordoned off and residents
are encouraged to drive slowly over the
cobblestone streets because any
vibration could ruin what's happening
inside while no tickets were sold these
performances will be remembered forever
[Music]
recorded in this concert hall built for
the star not the performer but the
instrument this one a more than 300 year
old Stradivarius known as Vesuvio is
kept like a jewel under glass here at
the violin Museum in Cremona Italy you
have how many microphones thomas corey
keep is in charge of recording which
notes to ultimately create a digital
database of precious instruments from
the museum each violin he explained can
produce roughly 100,000 so-called
articulations various sounds tones and
note changes
we try to capture the entire range of
the instrument from the lowest note to
the highest and from the softest note to
the loudest you can't just play with the
volume know it because the sound is
different they're so rare that some of
the most skilled musicians may never
touch these instruments so the idea of
the database is to democratize them
allowing anyone with the software for
the chance to play and at least
digitally these are the notes exactly
but the recording process is easily
disrupted the microphones when you're
sitting in here listening to your 32
different microphones what errant sounds
have you picked up from the city well
that's almost anything of course cars we
hear cars we hear dogs dogs barking
sometimes we hear stilettos Carmona's
mayor asked citizens to be understanding
of measures to keep quiet and if any
place would be it's here birthplace to
famed violin maker Antonio Stradivari
and the violin itself today Cremona has
more than 150 violin shops while they're
recording you have to tiptoe around the
museum I'm okay being light-footed is
part of the daily activity here maestro
Fausto cacciatore told us he's in charge
of moving this violin with some
Stradivarius is valued at more than 10
million dollars there's always a guard
nearby
sup and okay boy time will obviously
affect the acoustics of the instruments
Cacciatore explained that other news
remained so they're recording them now
with microphones so sensitive that
performers remove watches so the ticking
won't be heard we don't know how they
sounded 200 years ago so and we don't
know how they will sound in 100 years so
what we capture right now is the sound
of these instruments today in this hall
the challenge is to capture the pure
sound of this old instrument without any
of the noise pollution of today for CBS
this morning Seth Doane Ramona Italy
[Music]
auditorium notes yeah you don't know
what you don't know what age will due to
the instrument which is why they want to
record it now and if you have those
notes from centuries ago yeah and put
them to songs today yeah I like what
they're saying about even tiptoeing in
stilettos if you all could hear that
it's very difficult Tony I'm just saying
not try that at home